okay we're back
live
hi of a day
yesterday so we got some results to look
at and they're not great um they're not
terrible but they're not
great so we have this Paro F right here
right this is what carbs is
producing each of these points should be
a very very accurate estimate as well
based on what we're doing so these
parameters are
fixed entropy looks like it has a good
spread
97225 oh yeah it's resampling right
here so all these runs are the
same wait but then they shouldn't be
this different in terms
of their
something's weird here this dashboard is
a little
Jank no
runs do I just do this
offline I think I could just do this
analysis
offline this is would be kind of
heavier yeah I think that's what we're
going to do we'll figure out a little
bit of analysis offline I want to see
what's happening with carbs here uh this
is not what the algorithm should
be doing I don't think this is not great
performance I don't know if this is
carbs being weird or uh somehow the
usage of it
all I'm going to do this on
my main
box okay we're on the right
Branch um and now
correlate I'm going to we're going to
mess with this script a little
up so this
is harbs breakout full
interesting environment SL it should be
environment score right
refresh
and this environment variable
so we have our
data 180
runs five good runs hold on something's
something's Jank there because
I see way more than
right is a 200
right
okay well that's bizarre because that's
not what I see on the
table it's not what I see on the table
at all
178 RS carbs Break Out
full look at all
these environment
score
problem ah all of my charts are
wrong all of my charts are wrong
so the reason that uh we're doing this
as well the last point that puffer
provides is always a very very good
estimate because the last point that it
submits is an eval point
uh over a lot more
data the max is going to be much
noisier the thing is the parbs should be
correctly using the last Point as a
stable
estimate but this should explain some
stuff maybe
okay so now we can see that there are
actually only like 1 2 3 four five six
points above 200 it looks
like
um and if we look at the Paro
front yeah this is more
reasonable we can look at curves for
this as well
general I mean you can see
see the train curves are really all over
the
place I wonder now why is
that is it the reporting
interval it can't just be the reporting
interval it actually has to be something
to do with the
Dynamics because even like if you were
to smooth this right this is still all
over the place
all these ones down here these
experiments at the bottom we're going to
implement early stopping today so these
should just be uh removed
basically the charts are a little laggy
I'm not going to lie Neptune your charts
are a little
laggy better than you want to
be but still lagy
okay so here's
our our
data what else do we want
this
dashboard okay
so there's sections this is
just I'm a little confused as to how
this is getting sorted because like I
keep trying to sort these and it keeps
undoing my my
sorting um
this it's creation time and Y is going
to
be uh the the actual cost
you can see that this is not really
doing the thing we want which is biasing
towards longer and longer runs
there are some things I think we should
look at
for for
this I'm especially suspicious of this
point that's been resampled a million
times
9470 e
use razor uh what is this razor black
widow 75% with orange switches
uh the clicky but not too clicky
ones I like my Razor
keyboards they keep actually improving
them every generation as well like the
keyboards have gotten noticeably better
each version they don't just like sell
you the same
thing it's now it's got like it's got
like a really nice metal like nice cool
metal frame on it this wrist pad's
gotten way better better this is super
solid and really nice to type on Keys
feel better layout's gotten
better I'm sure some like mechanical
keyboard Enthusiast will tell me that
this is garbage but it's
uh pretty damn good keyboard to get if
you don't spend all your day on our
mechanical keyboards
I kind of just do all my peripherals
from Razer cuz they're like they're
always
solid it's just Apple for people who
hate the Apple
aesthetic I think Razer has orange
yellow and green uh the yellow ones are
like linear and Silent the orange ones
are like quiet and tactile and then the
green ones are the obnoxiously loud ones
that makes everyone hate you
also good morning Captain right and
early
oops what just happened
here had a
terminal there it
is used to being in a room with people
four plus oh
geez that's just obnoxious there's no
reason to do that
like if people complain that you have
tactile switches that are quiet it's
like whatever
but I had uh my freshman year of college
I had a roommate from Hell who had the
world's loudest mechanical keyboard and
would just play OSU until like 2 in the
morning and I mean he hit those keys so
hard that he had to switch the keybinds
because he broke a couple of them you
could literally hear it with the door
closed down the
awful okay so this is
insane um
I really wish I could just see this in
the Neptune UI I Ian I know I'm going to
have to build out our plot stuff more I
was hoping to avoid doing that
initially something's really broken here
though let me see if I can figure out
their UI because this would just make it
easier so
oh there it
is that's weird
hello I come here every now and then cuz
I think your work is so passionate thank
you we're currently just uh doing a
little bit of work on these hyper
parameter Suites um we got carb set up
to automated uh just tune all these
environments and experiments
automatically
but it's not quite doing what I want it
to do so carbs has this property where
it's supposed to be able to start off
doing fast experiments and then run
longer experiments once it becomes
confident of the result of those and
that does not seem to be
happening
um so yeah hyperparameter stuff is just
really really important generally for
all of puffer because it kind of makes
everything in RL just work faster better
and easier and then also any research
that do on top of that uh all your
experiments run faster so hyper pram is
like very very
important if you're interested in
getting getting involved with the uh the
RL stuff by the way it's pretty easy
we've got a fun Discord with a ton of
people in it and just lots of people
building all sorts of RL environments
many of whom came in with no prior RL
experience you just need to know how to
code
um here this is built by a contributor
this is built by a contributor this is
built by a brand new contributor these
two are built by new contributors all
these are built by contributors I mean
really the only ones of these that I
built I built two of the more complex
ones admittedly neural MMO 3 and MMO and
then I built this multi-agent snake
I mean obviously I run infrastructure
for all this but most of the ends are by
contributors I think I got parts of what
you
mean well I mean if I say it simpler
right so there are a bunch of knobs for
reinforcement learning experiments that
affect whether your runs are going to be
good or not whether you're going to
learn well or not and you need a way to
automatically tune all these knobs
that's what hyperparameter tuning does
so what we're currently doing is looking
at one very good algorithm in that space
and we're seeing whether uh whether that
algorithm has the properties that we
would want it to have in order to be
useful for the types of experiments that
we want to run
okay there we
go now can we do
gamma data scientists more intrigued by
RL and genetic algorithms genetic
algorithms aren't really used used for
training the agents uh but they are
actually used in hyper parameter search
so there are uses successful
implementations of genetic algorithms
for hyper parameter search and generally
the reason for that is that the RL
models have at least 100,000 parameters
sometimes millions or tens of
millions hyper parameter tuning
algorithm is going to have between five
and 20 parameters
so like 20 dimensional space is about
what you can operate on with
genetics now I will say that it looks to
me and I'm not super familiar with this
face but it looks to me like Gan process
based approaches have been
outperforming uh genetic algorithms for
a
while we did actually I implemented a
really simple genetic algorithm as a
Baseline and did okay
um I think the G in process face ones
are doing better at the moment
go yeah we caught
it gania so the algorithm that we're
using at the
moment this is a a very good algorithm
at least from our test to view carbs we
have our own Fork of it and we have have
you know our own little tweaks to
it
um but it doesn't seem to be behaving
exactly as we'd want it to and now this
is a very weird Quirk right here so it
seems like it launched the same
experiment a bunch of
times personal question where are you
based uh I'm a resident of Florida but I
usually spend a few mon once of the year
in
California I mean I work all this stuff
is remote it kind of doesn't matter
where I do it from so I spend a little
time in California because there are a
lot of people to meet out there travel a
little bit but for the most part I do
from wherever I just work from
wherever there might be a little bit of
moving around soon because we're getting
uh we got to buy more Hardware and I'm
going to have to maintain
that
oh all the sunny places yeah pretty much
I spent five years in Boston for my PhD
and uh I'm sick of being
cold welcome YouTube
folks so I have no idea what carbs think
is doing here um
this is very very weird to me
because I'm pretty sure all these
runs are the exact
same I guess I could add hold on new
morning what are your carbs per
amps uh I'll show you in a sec Captain
so this is a bigger carb sweep in which
we are doing batch size and stuff as
well um but the thing so the thing that
we're trying to get to work right now
that is not working is carb should be
finding longer experiments over time as
it gets more confident I'm in seal a
yeah
that's why the time zones I
guess it's 8:36 a.m. here
okay interesting
so I don't know what's up with this data
point I think this is just like randomly
happens to be very
close this purple
one yeah something's weird with this
point but whatever so if we look at all
the other points
here um
yeah see
around if we look at all the other
points
here is this really the variance from
random
seeds gan gan processes
yeah um it's in the carbs paper uh hebo
as well as like another Optimizer based
autum a
lot okay so this this is this is very
concerning so look at
this unless something is deeply wrong
here these are all supposed to be the
same hyper
parameters I welcome I say yeah
welcome
um these are literally supposed to
be the same hyper parameters
is it really
possible that there is that much
variation from seed to
seed well they're not supposed to but
look what carbs did
right look what carbs did so I put this
filter on and carbs has sampled the same
parameters like 38 times it really likes
these parameters for some
reason we can figure out why that is but
it for now it did do this
o5 I don't think that these are insane
hyper parameters either 94
97 yeah these are like pretty
reasonable oh learning rate maybe is a
little high but these are
pretty reasonable hyper
parameters so we have
30 I mean I think these aren't getting
applied
correctly but I think that they are
getting applied correctly because
because look at this all the rums they
take almost the exact same amount of
time so you know num M's bad size all
these
things I should add bad size to this
chart
uh yeah that's a that's a glitch with
carbs um but like I ignore the fact that
that shouldn't be the case Captain
ignore the fact that it did this for
some reason the question is now why the
results are so dramatically different if
they're all the
same so basically this bug is going to
this bug is going to let us find find
out something else that's
weird
right okay so look at this so we have
sampled here this is sampled for mini
batches um these so all the exact same
hypers and to be fair there is uh carbs
has a resample function that it could
just be calling too often
um if 3 five you know I think what's
probably happening is it's it has it
calls resample and it's probably just
always resampling this point instead of
resampling an arbitrary parito
Point yeah that's probably what I'm
going to do next Captain but I mean
there's something screwy here so look
these are all the
same unless okay the other possibility
is that these are just bad hyper
parameters that induce a lot of
variation from run to run
um so we have these charts we can see
these are all over the place right these
EV vals at the end are accurate
so here's a cool thing right with puffer
you see how there's this line is very
long
here that's because this point at the
end is an average of this many samples
so this is e+ 7 yeah so this is over 10
million uh over 10
million uh it gets at least 100 log
points which is at least 100
environments worth of logs but in
practice is going to be way way more
than 100 log points um and it'll keep
running like this for if whatever reason
here if it takes longer to get uh enough
logs it'll keep running
so you know it's almost weird that like
it's almost weird how they finish at the
exact same
batches I mean you can just see how
dramatically different these curves are
though um the next thing to check is
going to
be
charts it's going to be the losses
reasonable I mean these don't look
terrible
the value loss is not
good on
these maybe there's a problem with
puffer and value loss because now this
is this is three different environments
where I've
seen value loss be
screwy but I'm trying to think how that
could even be the case right how could
puffer have a problem with values L
could it be our
[Music]
J we can definitely do the pong runs
next do we have any m's that can
compare yeah certainly it's just that
the other implementations are way
slower I mean we've done this in over V
like various times in the past right
like we can we have parameters I mean I
guess it maybe it's worth checking them
but um you know we have parameters for
like classic Atari games and stuff like
that
we've tuned them a little differently
and puffer to make it faster um you know
the vast majority of RL repos out there
just painfully
yeah I mean that's the only thing that's
suspicious but it is
I mean it is possible that there's just
this much runto run
variation well this tells you why I mean
we can't fault carbs um we cannot fault
carbs for this
I think I should I think it would be
worth coming up with
a a good synthetic test for
carbs
um yeah I think it's worth actually
investing a bit of time coming up with a
really good synthetic test for carbs
that includes the cost ofwar
component and that kind of simulates how
uh simulates to trade off with update
Epoch and batch size and
stuff because I want to make sure that
carbs
is performing the way we
expect and that any
variations basically I want to have I
want to have the utmost confidence in
our hyperparameter tuning
I don't want to have to think like is
our hyperparameter algorithm not amazing
I want our hyper parameter algorithm to
be like known
amazing and the settings for that to be
known good and then I want basically to
isolate all of the problems to the RL
algorithm side
I think that's going to be the best
thing to do right
because I can actually
see you know carbs could be fine
here um with this much variation even
across
runs right it could be it's very
possible
that carbs is not running longer runs
here right it's just not running where
is
it sweet cost so it's just not going to
run longer experiments over
time because it's not confident in the
outcome of the
experiments right carbs has a predictive
model of performance and it is set up to
run longer experiments as it becomes
more confident in the outcome of the
cheaper experiments but if there's this
much variation then it can't predict
anything right then it's going to
regress to something that's only going
to be a little bit better than random
surf
SE it stop yes so now the question is
whether that this is a problem with
carbs or this is a problem with our
evals or the environment or like
stability or something
else um also
also hold
search because I found a bug in our
breakout
stuff not this
good I had the plots
misconfigured um so that it was showing
the max score instead of the last score
but this is is we still have carves here
with solving the environment so we can
solve the
environment time step for m
space so right now Captain I have
centered at it's a it's a log function
centered at 100 million that can go from
10 million to a billion and the standard
deviation is a quarter of an order of
magnitude
um so whatever that is in log space
what's a quarter of an order of
magnitude
um I I actually don't know how to do
that transformation in my head one order
of magnitude would be it like samples at
100 million but then you know standard
deviation could be 10 million or a
billion it's a quarter of
that in log space
got to go we'll be back soon
cool I'm going to work on this a little
bit I want to make a synthetic test for
cars want to make a good synthetic test
for cars
simulates
out um up an RL
G
there's that
he
spcer let's
see what do you have for
o check sweep reward where's success
rate
never hits the final goal
okay let's look at this for
eight well this is nice these curves are
nice um this junk over here is carbs
definitely being
weird uh let me show you by the way real
quick when you say you have to set up
parito front you literally just do
this well if the [ __ ] UI doesn't
break
God damn it
w so their UI is
broken so literally all you you got to
do is click that thing it's not working
on mine but that will give you the Paro
front looks like your reward tuning
matters a lot look at
this you see this reward tuning seems to
matter a
these are like ridiculously clean curse
you
know these are ridiculously clean
curves I'm surprised it doesn't jump
up you know this is the type of
environment where you would expect it to
like jump up in rows
so I mean here's the other thing I can
show you right
this is the other thing I can show you
is that if you just keep training it
like probably it'll go up more if you
just take one of these runs and keep
training it it'll probably get to five
at
least this is you're only training it
for like three minutes
man
code as soon as you finish this I'm
going to onboard or I'm going to help
onboard you to science side stuff if
you're interested in that so there's
your
motivation and I could use the help on
the science side as well
in blanket puffer policy with
lsgm is this the default policy wait is
this the default
policy can you link me this
dispenser I want to take a look real
quick and then I want to finish this
carbs
really it turns out there's a lot of
time to death if you do literally
nothing but dep
on
mobile uh let me see if I can find your
thing oh yeah here it is
is it just this Branch Tower
jeez yeah man this is a shitty
policy I'm surprised it does anything
so like literally that's just going to
flatten all the
data I think you should probably I mean
these experiments are now quick enough
that
um there are a couple things I would do
and actually you know this is going to
be this will be good for you because
this will help a little bit on the
science side for you with as well so
carbs is great but the problem is carbs
takes a bunch of experiments to get off
the ground and eventually we'll have
like nice ways of warm initializing it
and stuff before even thinking about ask
action masking man
um so cuz yeah that matters a lot but
it's it looks like your reward is doing
fine here you you could log like a legal
moves like like you could log like numb
legal moves or something that would be a
good idea um um but I wouldn't mess with
that just yet cuz that's going to be
trickier
on right right right right so this is
what I would suggest
doing okay um and this is where I had
all those Neptune plots come in
you actually have a fair bit of good
data here
right so this is what you can do um and
it's annoying in Wan you can't really
download your data to do this
automatically um but this is like
science side stuff that you'll probably
want to get involved with so like let's
take
your let's take your learning rate okay
learning rate and then on this side
we're going to have uh where is it
Towers those
cleared
off and
now I'm going to put
this okay perfect so you see
this right
here this tells you that for your
environment all of these
runs to the right these are all
wasted you can see that the stable range
for experiments for you
is this very very low learning rate
o1 to
o12 or whatever so what you can do is in
your sweeps right in your sweep
configuration and you might have to go
grab my ablation Branch to get like the
new configuration to make this easier or
it might work in the old one I don't
know um you can restrict your learning
rate sweep right to you know a generous
Bound in this region
so this is like 1 eus 5 or something or
1 e- 6 you can go from there
maybe even a little lower up to whatever
like around here is and then your
learning rate will be you know a stable
selected
parameter and then you can do the same
thing let's look at
Gamma
okay so
gamma you can see all your gamas are
from 0.9
[Music]
to about 0.96 or 097 so you can set the
range for
that right you can set the range for
that and then you can do
J
Lambda and
here again
91 9 s
maybe and if you do this what's going to
happen is that even your random search
even if you just run random search
you're going to get good experiments
quickly because you're only sampling
within the relatively stable range of
hyper
parameters so basically you're going to
increase the speed at which you can run
all of your experiments on this and then
once you do that you run a quick check
to make sure that your random sweep
produces you you know decent runs
quickly and then you can go rerun either
random or carbs with those nice new
ranges those like initial ranges uh with
new policies right and you can use the
new policy that I suggested which is the
two layers of comp 3D into the
lsdm that does that make
sense you see how much easier that is
than like messing with action masking
and it like you can just see on this
graph all these wasted experiments you
see how that's going to like so quickly
give you a lot of return on
investment some of the prams have a
logic check forces the value to have Min
Z
min0 it shouldn't force it to have Min
zero you should be able to increase the
Min and if you can't then that's
something that we have to
fix you should check both the uh the
demo in 2.0 but also check my ablation
Branch because I I've uh I've made some
nice changes there and I made a few
additions to
carbs but you see how like something
this simple is is likely to just like
dramatically speed up everything that
you
do this is why I spend so much time on
like hyper pram sweeps and stuff right
because like if I'm looking at how do we
make RL consistent and stable like this
is the first obvious place that you look
and you have the data to prove
it analyze each pip prepar for good rain
run better sweeps and then improve
policy yes
exactly and let me know if you need help
with the policy but it should be very
easy you just got to make sure the only
thing you got to make sure is that you
don't blow up if you uh if you implement
your policy and it goes to 2 million
parameters or something then you've done
it
wrong but there you
go this exact type of thinking by the
way this is like this is the type of
stuff that I'm going to want to show you
to onboard you to science side stuff cuz
it's like like I I'm really not a genius
it's like it's very basic stuff like
this that allows you to make huge
amounts of progress
on writing the other policy yeah so
write the other policy but like don't
throw away most of your
experiments I mean if you really want to
write a policy and just run the same
carb sweep on it you can do that it's
just going to take
longer but yeah technically if you only
have an hour to work on this
right then yeah I'd probably just do the
policy as well and overnight the
experiments because it'll take a little
longer to like think through and get the
hyper prams
right but you definitely want to do both
of these things and also this is a major
thing with uh with puffer is we're going
to want to basically have the ability to
make it easy to get the ranges the hyper
pram sweep ranges for your individual
environment correct so that when you run
all of your experiments you know you're
only exploring in the stable ranges and
we want to automate all that
stuff there you
go if there are no other questions I'm
going to go back to this synthetic carb
Shenanigans I want to get better at
writing good
policies yeah you can do that but the
thing is like like I think that you
think that there's a lot of magic there
and there
isn't like there's really not a lot of
magic
there like
here this is neural MMO 3 all right so
this is what I made in order to
make uh in order to do neural
mm3 it's
the whole policy right there it's got
some 2D conss it's got a discret
encoder it's got a multi-hot the only
tricky thing here is this factors trick
for multi-hot
encoding but like dude look at this
that's it that's the
policy and I had all sorts of more
complicated policies that did worse and
were
there might be uh there actually might
be like a bunch of outfit in policy
search type work but the thing is you're
never going to find it
manually like when we do architecture
work it's going to be automated work
that's supported by really good fast
sweeps right and like here let me let me
show you something as well I think I've
talked about this before this is the
last thing I'm going to give you for now
and then I'm going to go back to this
sweep stuff for
um
but okay so I think a lot of like the
motivation to like try to get good at
policies it comes from stuff like
this uh where it's like oh man look at
the policy that was used in open
ai5 like this is a complicated policy
that was written by people that really
know what they're doing and yes
but the thing is
structurally the reason that this policy
is so complicated is because DOTA has a
fancy State space that needs to be
partialed out so it's you're not just
putting into a flat encoder the core of
the entire network is this lstm right
here that's where like almost all the
parameters in this entire network are in
this lstm right here and then these are
just action heads right for the
different uh actions some of these are
multi- discreete most most of these are
discreete so this is just a multi-
discreete uh decoder like this whole
block except for this one attention
thing is literally just our three line
multi- discreete
decoder this unit attention keys this is
a little trickier I can explain this but
basically this is what happens when you
need to select a unit that you can see
rather than uh picking from a fixed list
of
things and then all this stuff at the
top is just an ENT encoder this is just
like a specific sub Network where it's
like hey uh the unit has a the this
specific Hero has a type let's embed it
uh we want to know whether you're
currently attacking let's embed that
Health attack region okay we'll embed
that and then they do this for
everything and then orientation okay we
cosine and sign embed this because it's
an angle and they just concatenate
everything and this is literally just
like a two- layer MLP and then over here
they do the exact same thing with all
the abilities and modifiers so like this
almost isn't even Network design like
there's very little required
understanding of like neural network
architecture literally all this is is
understanding the structure of the data
coming out of the environment and how to
sanely get that into a flat Vector
that's all this
is and then this thing here is like a
janky uh this is like a janky
multi-headed detention before
multi-headed detention existed um but
whatever that looks like this that that
looks like that is setting their
OBS this is encoding their
observations but I if I explain it that
way
like you don't need like there's no
knowledge here to know that you can do a
two- layer MLP right cu the actual
Network this is a two- layer MLP this is
a two layer MLP this is a two layer MLP
why do you use max pooling use max
pooling because you have a variable
number of entities and want them to be
encoded the same way regardless of what
order they're in okay that's it like
very very basic things and yeah there's
like this weird concat where they FC re
FC re this is just like a multi-headed
detention shenan thing um not really a
huge deal and that's it that's the whole
network so this is like the most like as
complicated as stuff
gets and the only reason this is so
complicated in the first place is
because of the structure of the
observation
data like you don't need any of this CU
you don't have data that's this
structure this won't help you cuz you
don't have data that
knowledge I'm G to write this I'm going
to write this synthetic section I'm
gonna get some breakfast
I'm hoping I get
to start running again next week and
stop being a
blob we're going to see how screwed up
my lung capacity is I definitely am not
going to be able to run a 5k I'm hoping
that I'll be able to run a couple
kilometers without
dying help the science once I get
towered climb yeah exactly I think that
that's a good plan is like finish this
environment up I like I'm trying I'm
kind of feeding you little bits of the
science side thinking as you're doing
these and um I'll on board you once you
got that
set a lot of it's very basic science
work but it's very it's like very
effective science
so we got to figure out how to model
this
negative and
then well I don't like this actually
because this is not going to
one so this gives
us base score maxes
score
maxes out at
one okay and now we need to modulate
it e
mod
sqrt of
let's
do log
2 batch
size
times square root of n many
batches oh no this is total time steps
okay and then it's batch size is going
to probably
be a square
root Times Square Ro
T batch size and then this has got to be
divided by
this two to the 4th right I'm just being
stupid h no I'm Dum okay eight
oh and then I got to do total time
steps
this has got to
be divide by log two and I can actually
just do number
six
okay and then time square root of n Mini
batches is
fine update EOD
what do we treat this as same thing
JX and then the only thing I haven't
accounted for is num
Ms I have not accounted for Num M's uh
which do I model this in here
more M's being
worse I think I I think I leave that out
for
is this is your score
mod then cost
mod you also need a cost
mod uh hang
on
okay cost
mod well this one is easy
right this is just going to be total
time steps over
100 and this is 100 million not
100,000
okay uh and then this is going to be
mini badge
size over uh the base mini batch size
which will say is 16
okay wait no it's
it's other way around
and anything else that affects
this dat
so we'll just put this as
cost and now what we should have is
score is base score uh score
Mod Time base
score and then we should be able to
return return score and
cost okay
and now what we get to do is
plate mod test
Parts
do
Neptune tag s FS
works
perfect now it's a little slow because
it's going to do a Neptune connection
per
um but I'm just going to let this run
we're going to probably have to tweak
this a little bit but we're going to see
what happens with this I'm going to be
back in I don't know about 10 minutes do
a couple quick things we'll check on
this and then I'll go to breakfast but
uh yeah let's see I wish I could make
this Auto Show so that it'll show the uh
the new points while I'm away but I
don't think that'll work
so anyways be right back
back look at
that
so sweet
then sweep
cost where's cost
what's what's up with this um Frito
front I mean this is like what you want
here CIS running time oh wait wait no no
no this is not all right
because yeah this is not the thing that
it's actually getting evaluated on
um let me
see so we're going to do
itic poost and then this is going to
have on the
xais we're going to
do
the Y
AIS well no that's not the right thing
we want to do on the
xais we want to do
cost
um which is up time do we call
it environment slash
uptime oh maybe this is right hold on
sis no it's not
yeah we need to add environment SL up
widget okay so here's our synthetic
front um
this is very
weird so it's possible that I've messed
up the test and it is possible that
um there's something with
carbs let me
see synthetic carbs observation score
and cost let me see if I I got this
right so this is a multiplier
right score
here you should be able get over one
quite easily
right let me
see so learning rates
now it should be at 0
rate and
gamma gamma should
be99 okay this is where gamma
is it's like using all the variables
here but
here so something
is off I
think this is with no noise as well this
should just be able to shred this
Baseline is it the cost component that's
messing with
it because like clearly this is not
is not what we want um let me try
something
cost so we'll keep the score
mod uh and then cost is equal to cost
equals
one so they all have the same cost now
and we'll run that and we'll see if the
errors are coming or the the lack of
optimization is coming from carbs not
correctly handling the cost rateof the
way it should be or uh something else
that I'm
missing so this will run pretty quick um
I am it's about 10 I'm going to go get
some
breakfast take a quick walk and
and I will be
back hopefully I'll be back in like an
hour I got a meeting at 12: hopefully I
can do a short uh short just analysis
thing before that but if not I will be
back in the afternoon on this um this
is this is like pretty basic hyper pram
stuff here but this is going to be the
basis of a
lot um pretty much at the moment they
just there too many sources of error
in RL the algorithm uh just seed
variance tons of stuff so really what I
want to do is I want to have a synthetic
test that convinces me that uh if your
samples coming in from the environment
are good that your hyper parameter
optimization is going to be solid
and yeah I think it's worth spending
some time on that uh for folks on
YouTube and join the Discord discord.gg
puffer you can check out live demos of
all of our RL stuff on puffer doai it
has links to everything um if you want
to help us out for free St the
repository really helps a ton and you
can also follow me on X where I post
lots of RL stuff